la semaine dernière on a diffusé une
vidéo de vous ai envoyé un vilain mot à
eric naulleau c'était jeudi beaucoup de
gens nous en ont parlé ce week end et
ensuite vous avez refusé de vue excusé
auprès d'eric terrible regarder pour
ceux qui avaient loupé si vous aviez
écrit à eric regarde c'est jean michel
maire qui écrit eric naulleau je viens
de comprendre que la seule chose que tu
as lu dans tpm paix c'est ton contrat en
revanche tu es un très beau profil
voilà félicitations aux direz vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je veux des excuses format avarie
organique qui ressemble à votre cul les
hommes d échelle de montcuq et pour
commencer dès
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quand tu sais que tu as entendu ce n'est
pas vous serez là tous les deux lundi
dans l'émission
18h40 venez tous regardent peut-être que
vous n'aurez pas longtemps il ne s'est
pas contenté de l'insulté il a défié
votre autorité c'est vrai c'est blessé
mais ça qu'aujourd'hui chaque
chroniqueur a mis dans cette boîte un
mot vous concernant un mot disant ce
qu'il pense de vous vous allez voir ce
sont des mots de passe ils sont guère
qu'ils ont souhaité garder l'anonymat
mais je vous dirai qui a écrit chaque
mot je suis une bukavu allez tu le dira
c'est parti vous pouvez commencer à lire
aller alors jean-michel si tu utilisé
aussi bien ta langue pour dire des
choses intelligentes que pour lécher les
données mille de cyril qui pourrait être
un excellent chroniqueur je sais à
présent que c'est pas la lecture c'est
pas votre meilleur
[Rires]
il a commencé la lecture elle n'a pas
voulu
s'il avoue jean-michel si tu l'utilisés
aussi bien ta langue pour dire des
choses intelligentes que pour lécher les
bottes de cyril tu pourrais être un
excellent chroniqueur savaient qu'ils
agissaient à votre avis isabelle non
c'est ben haim s'était juste à côté de
vous je vais balancer jamais aussi bien
traduite par ses proches jean-michel des
drôles des beautés pertinents tu es
vraiment le chroniqueur parfait voilà ce
que j'écrirai sur toi si j'étais un gros
mytho clairement favoris
attention je vous dire ça balançait tout
monde vous a mis dans l 2 d'après son
mari pas un petit mot 6 et 12 ans
jean-michel juste un petit mot pour
vérifier si tu sais lire si tu arrives
et si tu arrives à papa c'est moi je
vais lire gravé un cd
franchement quelle année la bonne hausse
et vous votez ici aussi
jean-michel juste un petit mot pour
vérifier si tu sais lire si tu es arrivé
jusqu'ici mea culpa
j'arrêterai de dire aux gens que tu est
analphabète attention jean-michel on te
reproche souvent des problèmes
d'articulation
mais moi je trouve que c'est une bonne
chose ça nous évite de comprendre toutes
les conneries de turin
fm veille
sinon proches que vous beaucoup plus
proche de vous ces attentions
jean michel tu es là depuis le début de
ses pmp d'impôt est un peu comme une vie
ce qui reste trop quand on monte un
meuble on te garde dans un coin même si
on sait que tu serviras cgb crise à mon
stage a été aussi qu'elle fait beaucoup
de déménagements cause de ces divorces
[Applaudissements]
c'est simple michel ne pas dire une
équipe civile que j'allais dans ce mot
est accusé d'être quelqu'un de serviles
cyril m'a dit je ne peux pas te laisser
dire ça jean-michel ne connaît pas le
mot servile dit plutôt que c'est un gros
[ __ ] gilot non non c is a annoncé
moi j'aurais dit dans les nuits
pollution l'eau qu'est ce qu'elle a dit
attention jean-michel à ta naissance tu
as dû choisir entre une grosse top et un
cerveau aaa et un cerveau très développé
je pense que tout le monde sait ce que
tu as choisi ça c'est un compliment
c'est keith à bakka khel un village à
lui
gilles ouais mais reste plus grand monde
on tombe comme la cgil et enfin bouder
qui à décrire il ya plein de mecs
aubervilliers qui te chercher bouder
savent où trouver je suis accumule
marocaine oui alors voilà donc c'était
sa punition ça va être bienvenue à
monsieur débute aujourd'hui ses
partisans voient mes jambes ça va